[Music]
i'm going to have a lot more to say
about that
tonight in the next couple days and be
able to take your questions but in the
meantime
what i'm going to do is sign this bill
got it thank you all appreciate it
haydn biden is here to stay the
president once again
dodging the media while signing his
nearly two
trillion dollar pork filled stimulus
into law it's now been 50 days
and he still hasn't held a solo news
conference
the president's set to deliver a prime
time address on the pandemic tonight
but it will be in a controlled
environment where he can hide behind his
teleprompter and won't have to answer
any tough questions from reporters
while biden's silent democrats are
saying this
we're about to pass a historic the most
progressive bill in american history
it's be it passing today i think i can
safely say
and i've said this to my colleagues in
the house on the democratic side
this is the most consequential
legislation that many of us will ever
be a party to republican senator john
kennedy sees things a little differently
and is summing it up this way
president biden says it's a coronavirus
bill
and my response is right
you know and the stripper really likes
you uh
i said the other day that calling this a
coronavirus bill is like
like calling harvey weinstein a feminist
and the wall street journal is warning
americans to get ready
for the most progressive democratic
steamroller ever
and says that massive stimulus is only a
taste
of what's coming all right katie we
already have a stripper analogy in the
show and greg hasn't even opened his
mouth
yet um he has a point though he doesn't
there's that he does have
he does have a point i love senator
kennedy's way of speaking
and boiling things down so the rest of
us can understand them
but if you look at this is the bigger
picture when you have nancy pelosi and a
number of people on the far
left celebrating this as the greatest
leftist achievement since fdr's new deal
it really goes to show that the biden
campaign wasn't exactly honest when it
came to what they were
portraying biden as we said that he
wasn't a moderate we knew that but he
was portrayed as a moderate they got
this bill through with
zero republican votes despite biden
saying he wanted to be
bipartisan and now you're seeing a
number of people pushing for permanency
when it comes to a lot of these payments
for these social programs that have
nothing to do with covet relief
and so as he goes out on the campaign
trail essentially to try and sell this
we're gonna see whether the quote shovel
ready jobs come to fruition
remember president obama said that never
actually happened and i think there'll
be a lot more scrutiny going to 2022
about whether that two trillion dollar
bill was worth it
all right juan i already know what
you're going to say you're going to say
it's so popular
but it's only popular because no one
knows what's in it and it's free money
so tell me
why you think this is such a great bill
besides talking about how popular it is
well first let me just say what a huge
win this is
for joe biden i mean i think he's good
by the way you talk about haydn biden
he's going to speak tonight right he's
going to have a solo news conference
next week
later in the month he's having a a
speech to the joint session of congress
i mean i don't see him as hiding but
maybe you see a disciplined president is
somewhat different than his predecessor
okay i'll give you that
or but in terms of its popularity okay
but in terms of its popularity you're
exactly right
and you know i just don't want to insult
the viewers 70 percent of americans like
this bill
you know it's like 49 percent of
republicans
like this bill uh and not only that you
have huge percentages that approve of
biden and the cbs poll out today
60 of americans approve of biden
so look jesse with 10 million fewer jobs
today than we had a year ago
when this coronavirus pandemic struck i
think americans are saying in those
popularity numbers
that government has a role to play in
helping
the american people helping small
business helping our schools
helping the unemployed get back on their
feet half of the money goes directly to
people
900 billion in direct checks
this is concrete help and it'll get 12
million
i think that's good that's why it's
popular martha i think the checks to
people are great
it's the rest of the steps that's
absolute garbage
well you know i mean it's hard to find a
situation where you're going to send out
1400
checks and extend the extra unemployment
for 300
all the way through september that
people are saying they don't like i mean
that that's you know when you're going
to send money to people
everybody's probably going to be on
board so i don't think it's that
surprising how popular it is
um but the other thing that i would
point out is that bloomberg did a study
we've had an extraordinary amount of
savings that has happened
over the course of the last year during
covet 1.5
trillion in american savings so that's
one of the reasons that you do see
a fair amount of the money that's going
out there going into the stock market
that's one of the reasons that we've
seen
big jumps in the stock market so it's
great to give people money
it's probably going to fuel some
inflation which will be difficult you're
latching on a ton
more debt onto the united states economy
and you're also in a situation where we
had 4.4 trillion
that already went out the door you've
got a trillion of it that's not spent i
don't know
any you know any company any american
family that would ever
try to pull themselves out of a hole by
digging the hole
deeper which is what we have done with
this bill especially at a time when
things are starting to open up there's
no stimulus that's better for the
economy than the economy opening up and
that's already happening
i was in new york today walking down the
street people were honking their horns
and i thought the only i haven't heard
honking horns in a really long time
there's only two reasons that you honk
your horn
one is if there's a lot of people in
your way or two is that there's a lot of
cars around you and i thought
that is one of the most beautiful sounds
i've heard in a really long time this is
coming back and i think it might have
been more helpful
to wait on this but we know that joe
biden said one thing we need to pass
this big bill
almost two trillion dollars so that we
can get to the next part of our agenda
and that's why he hasn't taken any
questions because he wanted to get this
thing through
so that he can get on to the next part
of his agenda and it's all about
spending a lot of people love that
and he did you know that's he got
elected and you're right one it's
popular
but that make no mistake this is
enormous amount of spending and there's
more to come
all right let's go to gutfeld
exclamation point which you can see in
april at 11
o'clock he will be referred to now with
an exclamation point so no one confuses
him
so greg i don't know what your reaction
was when i saw joe biden sign the most
expensive and most progressive bill
in american history and then just walk
away without taking questions
there was something really arrogant that
i just didn't like
seeing that how did you feel well i was
more upset by the fact that i was sold a
bill of goods i was told by people
some on this table that joe was middle
of the road
in fact he was in the middle of the road
and a left-wing
steamroller went right over him we we
predicted that he would have no spine
and boy were we right you know and also
just to reiterate saying people like
this bill
is like saying people like money except
you don't know where
the money is coming from it actually
comes from the people
the money given to you is nothing
compared to the money that they're
actually taking from you
over over time so don't forget that so
saying you like this bill
it's almost like saying i like my iphone
i like my basketball shoes but i really
don't know where they're made in china
and i really don't know who makes them
slave labor right
so but as long as you don't know where
the stuff comes from that's okay i love
foie gras until i find out how it's
actually made
and i love it a little a little less so
how big is this bill
it's larger than the total amount paid
in individual taxes in 2019 that was 1.8
trillion
so my theory on this one was i think the
republicans blew it
they should have said okay you can have
your 2 trillion
but i want to add another 2 trillion
let's make this bill
4 trillion because there's no difference
between 27
and 29 trillion in debt we could have
actually gone conservatives and
libertarians could have just said no no
no no this is too small instead of two
trillion make it four trillion
and then that extra two children two
trillion tax rebates
give everybody a year tax a tax holiday
because that's the only way americans
are going to come out ahead on this you
think you're getting something for
nothing no
this is coming from you of course it's
popular because you don't know where
it's coming from
for trolls as they say right
yes come